[Music]
so I suspect that you've found some
strange allies in this space because
here I am I don't know if I qualify the
strange ally may may be possible but but
basically you're you're a lefty right
you're you can consider yourself
progressive or if you had to describe
your your political views I called
myself throughout the book of leftist
feminists I mean I wanted to make it
clear that you know I wanted to make
that clear yeah yeah I have not shifted
right okay so well first off what is a
leftist feminist mean to you I guess
let's define that middle yeah I mean I
one point I suppose in in my career
would have called myself a Marxist
feminist so I mean it means for me you
know I believe in redistribution and I
believe in a sort of feminism I mean I
guess I was steeped on what would have
been called Marxist feminism or
materialist feminism that took and also
but that had a kind of emancipatory
direction I mean and I'm also somebody
very interested in psychoanalysis so I
use the psychoanalysis a lot so I mean
it's a bit of a motley collection of
influences but I left I mean I mean that
I think the economic level is um
something that I want to factor in
issues about class I got I wrote a book
about pornography a long time ago that I
got interested in the subjects had
written about hustler magazine and that
my point was that the feminist
anti-pornography movement had not taken
class into consideration at all and that
hustler was not just about gender it was
also about class and a sort of attack on
elites so I'm kind of trying to factor
those levels into the sort of you know
thinking that I do yeah so I'm curious
so as a leftist feminist then
potentially or a formerly Marxist
feminist I haven't heard that one before
but all right there we go
do you find that your allies right now
are coming from quarters that don't
quite make sense to you yes the the
situation I mean I should just say the
situation on campus makes no sense in
terms of who what groups think of
themselves as on the left and I'm sort
of
yes about whether a lot of the activism
is what I would call left-wing even
though you know the right loves to
hammer the the left-leaning students but
I mean the student student activists are
more and more acting like authoritarians
and you weirdly have the conservatives
and libertarians acting like liberals
and you know promoting free speech and
and that sort of thing so this is this
is now you're telling me my life story
yeah yeah well that's because it's my
life story too in trying to myself makes
sense of this political moment and yes
finding myself getting a lot of invites
from places like you know various
libertarian and conservative leaning
foundations that I do you know would not
really have had much to say to
previously
yeah how does that feel for you you know
like when you're getting invited to
these things that previously you either
would have had major political
disagreements I mean I'm guessing
especially if they're libertarian groups
they're never telling you what you can
say or anything like that not yet you
probably wouldn't go to a place yeah
that would anyway but that you have
these new allies must be kind of weird
for you I mean I know what this feeling
is that's why I'm curious yeah it is and
I mean so there's an area that we
overlap we're in agreement about but you
know I think it is more the economic
issues I mean like I did an interview
with Reason magazine they go ups go SB
who you know it's really smart
interesting guy knows a lot of social
theory but you know I suppose if we
started talking about more economic
issues you know I'm not somebody who
wants to let the poor people starve you
know so we're I think that's probably
where I depart you know yes we agree on
free speech we're probably less in
agreement about you know regulation that
sort of thing I don't know that they
want to let the poor people start but
they just don't want us or the
government involved that but that's a
that's a whole other topic but I just
think it's interesting because as
someone with those beliefs which I fully
respect I think you're finding the
allies that I've found lately is anyone
on the Left defending you I mean is
there has been that has there been any
outreach of leftist professors or
anything on the
I think there's some well that should be
your intellectual allies right the
people that agree with you on everything
that you write about yeah I'm at a teach
about are they offering you any shelter
yeah that's I guess well I get a lot of
supportive email from people saying I
would be afraid to say what you're
saying in public so I know that there's
like an underground layer of support and
I mean I think that it's generational
some of the sort of older generation of
leftists somebody like Todd Gitlin who
was you know an SDS person he teaches at
Columbia is written also about the free
speech issues on on campus so there's
certain people out there but it's no
it's been a little I'm not gonna say
lonely but I I feel someone on my own in
trying to make sense of this situation
and you know doing a better job of it do
you think it's possible that you're what
should be your allies especially in the
public space I was mentioning to you
before in the green room that I see all
these celebrities and comedians that
when DeVos did this stuff and rescinded
these Obama era editions that basically
they were all tweeting about how divorce
and Trump or Pro rape and they hate
women and all these these are these are
leftists who you probably agree with on
all on all the economic stuff all the
social stuff all of that stuff but
they're doing you actually an incredible
disservice is what I would say and I
looped you in on one tweet when Chelsea
Handler tweeted something about this and
I said I'd love to have you on come on
with Lauren that's no I would shoot
myself right but think about that I mean
that's that's actually kind of
fascinating I would guess that if you
and Chelsea sat down about most
political issues you would agree on most
things but then should they tweet these
kind of crazy over-the-top things and
then they're actually undercutting what
their academic allies should be doing I
think it's a really fascinating little
piece of this I have a sort of allergy
to self-righteousness and you know I
mentioned having written about hustler
magazine and I suppose it's what drew me
to somebody like Larry Flynt is an
interesting figure you know I was kind
of interested to sort of weave through
the over-the-top outrageous stuff he
said and to try to make sense of some of
the politics behind
what he was saying and this sort of
instant position taking that people like
that are engaged in I mean you're
talking about Chelsea Handler you know I
I'm not somebody who ever really wanted
to be a pundit I wanted to sit and think
about some of these issues and think
about the contradictions and the
complications and that's what I've tried
to do in in my writing and I think
there's well this may be sound sound the
self congratulatory I think there's too
little of that and it may have something
to do with Twitter and you know the you
know sort of instantaneous opinion
forming that is required of people who
are in Twitter but I don't think it's
interesting and so I guess I'm kind of
veered toward the people who are saying
things that complicate the situation as
opposed to simplify it yeah well that's
why we're here doing this so that we can
get some of that across yeah all right
let's talk a little bit about your book
what's the exact quote that you have on
the front of the book I have it here
somewhere but it's pretty perfect about
feminism if this feminism hijacked by
melodrama yeah this is feminism is
feminism hijacked by men that did not
yeah yeah that's good that you know that
that was that was a very on the spot
question but you are correct so what
what is happening to feminism there
there I see from my audience and just
from so many people that I respect in
the public space right now just an
abject rejection of modern feminism
these are not people who dislike women
these are people who want equality of
opportunity these are people who date
and sometimes are women in the first
place so I don't think it's about hating
women in any way but that modern
feminism has just been morphed into
something sort of crazy how's that for
an opening it's a broad question okay
that's what that wasn't a fun it's a bit
hard to answer that you know here's
where my Freudian side kicks in I mean I
I feel that in the current situation or
in relation to these questions about
sexual assault or what's going on in
campus in terms of sexual politics I do
feel that there's been too little self
scrutiny on the part of women who regard
themselves as feminists as opposed to
the scrutiny of like male sexuality male
aggressivity and it was one of the
things and this is probably one of the
more controversial sections so the book
where I tried to write about how much
drunken sex binge drinking you know
could condition sex there is on campus
and how much you know women are
reluctant to analyze their own
participation in these situations or our
own conflicts about sexuality so you
know that's something where again I was
kind of trying to complicate the
situation as opposed to just say men are
predators you know male sexuality is
aggressive and bad and women are these
sort of violated innocence so I feel
like there's just too little I may be
not saying this incredibly well but you
know I think like too little
introspection about our own sexual sort
of participation right so even though to
write about that or talk about that I
know that there's gonna be a certain
amount of people will say well you're
victim-blaming yeah that they're already
going to put the onus on you even though
you're just you're really talking about
personal accountability to some degree
yeah I mean you know somebody's using
force against you that's not a situation
where one needs to talk about personal
accountability but in terms of drinking
and the kind of complicities that arise
in in those situations and the ways that
I think you know I'm a teacher and I
think universities should be in the
business of educating students and
helping them figure out how to be more
autonomous how to be more self examining
as opposed to this layer of regulation
that you know it has taken the place of
education so that's what I'd like to see
more of you know and I think
self-examination honest discussions
about what happens in these sexual
situations and alcohol-fueled situations
so you know I'm kind of pragmatic about
it yeah I mean speaking of pragmatics
how much do you think just social media
in general
has affected this whole conversation
because I would imagine that a lot of
times some of these cases are brought up
because the next day when when they wake
up hungover and everything they suddenly
realize there's five pictures of them
doing crazy things you know I mean
drinking and a funnel in their mouth and
taking bonnets or whatever they're doing
and I think back to my college days I
mean I did pretty much everything you
could think of the idea that now
everyone's walking around with cameras
doing all these things it just it's
almost like they're creating like a
hostage situation but they're the guards
and the hostages at the same time yeah I
think that's really true and it's
something I spent a long time and about
a year trying to have conversations with
my own students about this issue of
sexual assault and what was really
happening and I found out a lot of
distressing things I mean particularly
distressing if you've been a feminist
for quite some time and think by this
point in the evolution of human history
women should not have such a hard time
saying no or knowing what they want in
these in these situations and you know I
found out I think that a lot of the
drinking has to do with particularly on
the part of women not really knowing
what they want and so drinking
themselves a lot also is not to actually
have to decide in situations you know
yes or no do you think that's more
uniquely a female trading I it may be
you know I had an interesting
conversation with Susie bright the sex
activist who said that she works with
college students a lot who many most of
whom have never had sex sober and are
appalled at the thought that she would
even try to do that but well it's a
ridiculous thing to do sober I think it
would actually seem but what I was going
to say about the social media part so I
I in talking with students and I had a
conversation with a class one of my
classes once were and I repeat this in
the book where somebody said something
like I would they were they were
moralizing about a movie that I'd shown
and about the sexual choices one of the
characters had made and they're
moralizing you know just seemed I wanted
to sort of puncture it a bit so I said
something like you know when I was in
school we all thought about
we talked about liberation and you know
sex is pleasurable you guys seem to
think about sex is just simply a harm
and a potentially destructive thing and
I feel kind of sorry for you and one of
the students said well yeah sex can kill
you so I started thinking that well this
was this generation that was the first
post AIDS post HIV generation they've
all had this you know god-awful forms of
sex education where the destructive
harmful sides of sex have been
emphasized to them but I talked to the
student who said this he'd graduated we
had an email conversation and what he
said was what I meant was social death
that social media like everybody knows
what you did the night before and you
can be sort of killed publicly because
of these these choices that you've made
so I do think there's something about
them feeling like they're in a kind of
fish ball that that does change the the
tenor or the sense of the experience of
it and and I think this you know the
after the regrets in of the aftermath or
the feeling that you know many months
later will wait I didn't actually
consent to that I think social media
does have something to do with the the
way these the ways these situations are
construed later as harmful we're in the
you know president in a moment that they
happened you know it was just a sense of
confusion yeah so that's really
interesting so basically it's a
compounding of really poor sex education
in general or or just attaching a
certain amount of fear which may at one
time have been justified and then you
add the social media now you really got
like this this toxic mess there yeah and
the other thing is that I think there
are just a lot of messages on campus
aimed at women I mean everywhere you go
the conversation is about assault so I
think there's an I mean almost a kind of
encouragement to frame experiences as
having been assaulted or non-consensual
after the fact yeah so that all seems
very consistent with something that I
see on the left lately that we've talked
a lot about here that
left at least right now seems to really
value victimhood they think that
victimhood is virtue so it sort of makes
sense you you can't talk about sexuality
in a way that's empowering you have to
talk about it in a way that creates a
victim situation for you because then
you have sort of authority to talk about
it do you think that that's a fair I
would step back from that a little bit
and say that you know I I think the
attention to social justice on campus is
a valuable thing so I you know I do want
to say there have been people I mean
there's you know who are more
marginalized who are victimized whose
identities have been I have subjected
them to various forms of violence so the
UM I dislike the language of
victimization you know getting as broad
as that at the same time there is a way
that those positions them you know and
it comes under the rubric of identity
politics let's say you know that the
identities that have been have been
marginalized I mean do you attract a lot
of attention but you know both in the
curriculum and not in the curriculum to
some degree to rectify you know those
sort of you know errors of history in
the past but you know so that does play
into all of these things sort of I think
converge around this notion of sexual
victimization at the moment including
you know then this this layer that comes
down from the did come down from the
federal government in the form of title
nine yeah so how do you unfurl all that
I mean how do you as a feminist take the
power back now do you see a movement
growing on there I haven't really seen
it I I hope it's there well I do hope
that you know if this doesn't sound
grandiose at the book that I wrote it
will have some effect and you know what
I was able to do was um I got access to
two title nine reports about this
professor and I mean I was in receipt of
a lot of other actual title nine reports
from people who sent me both professors
and students who sent me the the
documents from their cases so I went
through
using all the critical skills that I've
developed in my many years as a leftist
feminist and you know you know kind of
close analysis of the sort of decisions
that the title nine officers were making
in this case and I talked about how
capricious the the judgments were how
gender biased
you know how steeped in stereotypes
about male and female sexuality they
were so you know that's something that
there hasn't been an opportunity to do
to look at how these judgments are being
made and and and to contest them because
as you know I've said all of this has
happened in in behind closed doors
there's been no oversight no daylight no
transparency so I think more
transparency on the this process and I
also think transparency or discussion
about sex on campus and particularly
heterosexual relations generally that
needs to happen yeah but basically
you're saying if you were a young
professor these days you probably
wouldn't want to teach in the California
system knowing that they're gonna keep a
lot of this stuff in place yeah you'd
rather go somewhere else where you're
not gonna have to just deal with it
pretty in effect you know I don't think
people have all the opportunities in the
world it's not like you can vote with
your feet you know when you're in a bad
job market which you know at academia
now is quite a bad job market I don't
think it's something people generally do
I tend to do like when you're offered a
job somewhere to look at the title nine
policies you know I'm not sure that's
happening yeah let's talk about some of
your other academic interests what's
exciting you these days we can move on
from title nine for a moment yeah I
think I'm still kind of figuring out
this you know we haven't gotten caught
up in this in this situation and you
know here we are talking about policy
issues I'm not at somebody who ever saw
myself as a policy person I mean I'm
very interested in writing and issues of
style and I've said that one of the
things that happened to me in writing
this first Chronicle
it was I have a lot of envy of writers
like somebody like Philip Roth who feels
a lot of freedom on the page and I wrote
a book a number of years ago called
against love a polemic which is a sort
of attack on on monogamy and talking
about the elephant in the room and long
term coupledom which is the fact that
sexual desire often doesn't persist as
long as you know a long term 30-year
marriage does so and that was a book
where I found myself feeling a lot of
freedom on the page to like figure out
all the metaphors about monogamy and you
know it's like a premature grave and so
in fact what interests me is that like
figuring out a level of freedom
stylistically in the stuff that I write
about so policy discussions it's not
does not really lend itself to to that
am I good at it you may not love it but
I mean you know what you're talking
about this obviously at least in this
case it's very personal to you so you
know it out I mean it you know it's this
has been an interesting experience for
me
because I did feel like I was sort of
called on to kind of step up and say
things publicly that might be
controversial and risk whatever sort of
repercussions might come but it didn't
make me interested in issues about
democracy you know and the American
tradition and I've tried to learn more
about stuff like due process and why
it's important so something about the
the voice of American writing you know
from people like Melville or Twain and
Huckleberry Finn and and the sort of
freedom on the page that American
writers have felt that I feel like I
have borrowed from him in my own work
there's some way that I think that has
my thinking about being a writer has
changed somewhat by being finding myself
in this situation of being accused of
things and having to take a public
position about freedoms and rights it
was a bit of a convoluted and although
but I get it I mean it's interesting
because
as a professor you should have the
ability and the freedom to not only
teach what you want in your in your
class but also to be writing about the
things that you want so really you're
just asking for them for the things that
in some way you probably have already
yeah I went to art school and started
out as a visual artist and then a video
artist so I'm not a traditional academic
and I just the other night had the
chance to speak at my alma mater San
Francisco Art Institute and realized how
much of being part of or being schooled
in a kind of avant-garde tradition that
did have to do with pushing back against
social proprieties and an aesthetic
norms like how much that's influenced my
work so even in writing about this wonky
thing title 9 I find myself kind of
wanting to take those liberties that are
both part of this artistic tradition but
also like this American the freedom you
know something like Walt Whitman I mean
who's the most known for expressing a
kind of sense of America as a sense of
personal possibility and liberty in
terms of writing and voice you know so
to incorporate all of those that history
and that tradition
you know in my work so I know that
sounds weird and and highfalutin though
but it's what's been on my mind after
having gone through this whole thing
yeah so I've only got one more for you
nice a nice segue of that which is what
would you say to the other professors
students administrators all of the
people that that see some of the
nonsense that you've had to deal with
that are just afraid to talk I get so
many emails from people I'm afraid to
post your Facebook clips I'm afraid to
say this my brother won't talk to me
anymore
all of that stuff has someone that now
is on the other side as so many of my
guests have been they've staked out some
position and they were afraid probably
lost some friends didn't get support in
ways that they wanted but then made it
to the other side is someone that has
done that or at least is in the process
of that what's the best thing that you
could say to those people I think
there's two levels of fear you know
there's a fear of social you know
disapproval that happens on Twitter or
social media and that I would just like
don't even think about that but there
real material fears like the fear of
losing your job and your health
insurance and you know possibly your
house when you can't meet your mortgage
payment so I think what I try to do in
my own situation was to separate out the
real fears from the those other fears
you know the fear of people disapproving
of what I would say so I did try to
think very seriously about was I likely
to lose my job if I wrote about the
title 9 process and I decided that no it
wasn't a realistic fear I did not think
my university would fire me and that
turned out to be true and you know could
I live with being disapproved of on
Twitter well yes so I think that it's
about not you know it's about avoiding
paranoia and you know and and being
realistic and taking realistic risks so
I do think that's what I did I tried to
kind of separate out what was an
acceptable level of risk and what
wouldn't be an acceptable level of risk
if I didn't have tenure and would be
likely to lose my job maybe that would
be not an acceptable level of risk yeah
well I have to say I've thoroughly
enjoyed this I mean this is what it's
all about to me people that are having
an honest conversation that sometimes
get thrust into a conversation without
having wanted it in the first place but
then use it for something else no I wish
you luck on this adventure we should do
this again and do it in you know maybe a
year or so or who knows what will happen
in the next year but we should do it
again and just sort of get an update on
this and see if some of this stuff
actually if some of the brush has been
cleared and maybe people are thinking
about this a little more I would love to
actively all right and you guys can find
out more about Laura and her work and
her books and all that good stuff at
Laura Kipnis com
[Music]
you